[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
today's topic
horsepower
let's find out more about that in a
moment but let me first introduce my
intrepid co-hosts gary o'reilly gary
hey neil all right dude a former soccer
pro and an announcer in the uk and then
you came stateside
and you did some announcing here too is
that right
yes that's right once again a loss of
american jobs
[Laughter]
that was chuck nice chuck
good to have you what's up love you too
man
so gary what what's going on today we
got horsepower yeah we do and it's i
wanted to look at horsepower in a
variety of different ways not just the
output of an engine or a motor i mean
kentucky derby is nearly upon us and it
made me think the original horsepower um
i mean i think of a species that has
helped advance the human civilization
more than a horse and i come up with
nothing it's the horse has been so
important so pivotal
and then i think
what
is it the physiological breakdown of the
horse's internal combustion system
how does that operate what's going on
from there and then
what kind of fuels do you have to bring
in it can't just eat hay
and then run it over 50 miles an hour so
i wanted to find out
how this was going on what is taking
place right so if eating hay was all
that mattered then cows would run 55
pounds
and that that might not be so good
sick
we'd all go hungry
here elsie
you ain't catching my ass
so we need an expert in equine
physiology and we've we think we've come
up with just that person our guest today
is dr sarah white springer
now the good doctor is from
texas a m in the department of animal
science and she's an assistant professor
in equine physiology
she's a specialist in equine nutrition
and exercise physiology her research has
involved things the performance and i
love this term performance improvement
in equine athletes how fantastic is that
you see them as athletes focusing on
mitochondrial adaptions to diet
and exercise and skeletal muscle
bioenergetics how about that one and uh
if that wasn't enough
dr white springer is quite talented in
the equestrian sport of dressage or as
you might want to call it
horse dancing horse dancing okay so
let's meet our guest shall we after that
all right
all right
welcome to star talk sarah thank you and
thank you for that introduction that was
you're right i do make up half of those
words
they sound good don't they i really do
put that on a business card so i'm just
delighted that someone like you exists
because otherwise i'm looking at horses
and i'm saying who's managing this who's
who is anyone on top of the situation
here and i'm as an academic i want to
know that there's some academic brains
behind whatever else i see going on in
this world it gives me hope for the
future of civilization so did gary
exaggerate or i think he's right when he
says we built civilization on the backs
of horses oh yeah yeah i mean um you go
back right to the very beginning and the
whole reason horses were domesticated
was to help people move from one place
to the next and to move their things
and we've just kind of taken that to an
extreme when we think about our equine
athletes and
we label them as such because they
require the same intricate management
and dietary intervention and training
protocols that human athletes do
and so it's really kind of an
interesting way to look at the horse
so you're saying that a horse with a
what is a poor horse diet like i'd have
never seen a horse sitting around eating
cheeseburgers and potatoes
you know i have seen a horse eat
something some more but not quite a
cheeseburger
yeah so it depends on the horse so each
horse has its own nutritional
requirements and if those requirements
aren't being met then that's a poor diet
and when you think about the athlete his
requirements are going to be much higher
than a horse that we call them pasture
ornaments ones that sit out in the
pasture and don't really do much for a
living and so if we're not feeding that
horse correctly to meet his requirements
primarily protein vitamins minerals and
energy then he won't be able to perform
at his maximal capacity wait sarah isn't
that just a known diet why is that still
an active area of research i want the
horse to run fast here's food put it in
the horse the horse runs fast
yeah it's very very tom brady very sad
yeah yes we needed tom brady and horses
um
so
well that's a loaded question so the
first part of your question is don't we
already know this part of it we do um
part of it as far as the macro minerals
or the macronutrients i'm sorry so
energy protein those kinds of things we
kind of have a good grasp on we don't
have a grasp on vitamin and mineral
requirements we know what will prevent a
deficiency but we don't know what will
actually optimize performance and a lot
of that goes into
how these vitamins and minerals are used
in the body so my interest in skeletal
muscle health we're learning more about
certain minerals that might actually
help the muscle
either prevent it from being damaged
during exercise or help it to recover
more quickly
after some sort of exercise event
because exercise is a damaging stressor
and so if you consider a horse in
training the exercise is probably six
days a week then we really need to make
sure we're feeding to optimal potential
yeah and of course the fast return from
injury i mean that's true for any sport
people any any sport where money is
involved that you know days matter days
time is money
yes and especially in horses because
they're super duper expensive to train
let me just just we were on the same
page could you remind us who maybe
remember
long forgot
the whole role of the mitochondrial
cells in energy production
the nails
yes mitochondria for those of you that
took biology and are going to have ptsd
are the powerhouse of the cell
so they are the organelles responsible
for producing energy during times of
increased need so exercise is the kind
of number one thing we think about but
mitochondria are active all the time and
they are constantly producing energy for
all of the things that our body needs to
produce energy they have to move
electrons through the electron transport
chain you've probably heard of that
before
and we have learned that different
horses move electrons differently and
based on which complexes they're using
they can actually produce more or less
damaging byproducts during exercise
and so we're trying to find ways to
manipulate that right so the stuff goes
in but all stuff comes out too and you
got to deal with that are there
different types of mitochondria those
that perform certain tasks and then
those who perform slightly different
tasks so we don't know as much in the
horse as we do in humans in humans we
know there's two populations of
mitochondria there's one called the one
population called the sub sarcolemmas
and so those are lit
well come on sarah just
back it up all right
talk about it she gave
i need to like spell it out on the thing
yeah exactly
say it again though you said it very
quickly sub sarco level okay
subcircle limbo all right
so the muscle fiber is surrounded by a
membrane called the sarcolemma
and so the mitochondria the
sub-sarcolemma mitochondria reside just
below the sarcolemma
is exactly what she just said
soccer
exactly i just didn't hear it it sounded
like she said subway sandwich or stuff
like that yes
that also can fuel your mitochondria
okay okay and then the other population
is the inter myofibrillar so within the
muscle fiber are myofibrils
and then the inner myofibrillars then
live kind of within that inner within
the myofibrils so between okay so the
the name by their location basically
right yeah okay yeah and we know in
humans that they operate differently but
we don't know what that means what the
implications of that are
in the horse we really don't know much
of anything
so um we're trying to learn more about
that to see if we need to be taught of a
population of mitochondria unfortunately
this is all based on research dollars
and research dollars are quite hard to
come by in uh equine athletes right so
we're limited so you should teach them
how to throw a football
and you get all the money you need hey
we're working on it
i may have one intellectual patent going
just to make sure i can retire oh good
good doctor a horse has
something like 55 liters of lung
capacity
as opposed to a human that might have
about six
yeah but what is what is what is that
ratio comparative to the horse's size
because like 50 55 liters means nothing
if the if it's a giant horse i mean
because you would have to make it
relative to what is the size of the
average human the needs of the muslim
muscular the skeletal exactly so how how
do you think about how much oxygen is
going in and out of a horse with each
breath
so it's just like in a human where we
call it vo2 that volume of oxygen
consumed um and they have a vo2 max that
is exponentially higher than a human
part of that is um lung capacity and
ability to exchange oxygen through the
lung to the blood the other part of that
is what we call a splenic contraction so
the horse is really stinking cool he
blood dopes himself every time he starts
exercising they have a large spleen how
is he blood how is a horse blood doping
dog come on that's that's that's that's
a secret first of all let me just say
that is totally dope yeah i'm not even
yet so they have a really big spleen
that holds red blood cells and as soon
as they start exercising that spleen
contracts and just dumps those red blood
cells into the bloodstream that's called
blood doping that's for sure that's
blood doping they just do it all on
their own
wow now let me tell you okay professor
what you need to be doing is forget all
this research on the horse
what you need to do is figure out human
beings can do that for themselves yeah
forget the horse and you will be the
richest woman in sports no kidding
so we just need to grow human spleens
larger or increase their capacity to
carry red blood cells there you go what
if you took what if you took a horse and
made it train at altitude and then
brought it down to sea level like they
do with track and field athletes does
that have a similar effect on the spleen
so they've tried that and the answer is
no
um it doesn't because their splenic
contraction is so efficient you can't
really help it it already works at a
really high level working at peak
efficiency yep
and this comes from the horse being a
fight-or-flight animal right he needs to
be able to run fast and for a while
to outrun the lion and yeah because
because a horse is
like other four-legged horsey-looking
things like zebras and things they're
food for predators right right
herds they run in herds yeah so that's
why that maybe that is that's why horses
are so jittery because you could be a
lion coming up behind it yeah right
exactly yeah that's why they're always
on the lookout and you'll actually find
it's quite interesting in the wild
stallions will have very small ears and
then mares will have very large ears and
the reason for that is that the mares
kind of keep an eye out on everything
and so their larger ears help them to
hear any predators they keep an ear out
for everything
okay dad jokes on dad jokes yeah
it's just an interesting
thing that you don't think about i don't
i guess if you're not a weird horse
person like me but um yeah i just think
it's a really cool there's you know
little fun facts that i like to throw
out in my class so you guys get some of
them too there's something else i heard
from my sister who's a horse person
that the horse with those big old horse
eyeballs
which are on the side of its head
that
when it is down grazing
it has much better view behind it
like
340 degrees or 320 degrees out of 360
than when the horse's head is up
so that when it's grazing it has more
latitude
yeah yeah and it's actually quite
interesting that's the reason the
horse's head is designed as it is
because he's a grazing animal so his
eyes are really high up on his head that
way if the grass is high he can still
see around while he's grazing so they
don't get bitten in the ass yeah
good luck with that the most delicious
part
but interestingly about their eyesight
because their eyes are on the side they
can't see directly in front of them
so most people when they approach a
horse they want to come at the front
once you get about a couple feet away he
can't see you anymore yeah
so that's actually a really it's a
threatening way to approach a horse it
really is i found that out the hard way
there was a term that popped up
and
respiratory coupling
which
it's
mainly in mammals that run so how is
that a thing and what is that thing
so yeah it's really interesting it's
called respiratory locomotory coupling
and so
what it means chuck did you hear that
one yeah well that was easy
everybody i mean everybody knows the
locomotion
we all got slow down for chuck okay go
on okay
so their breathing is coupled to their
movement and that's only once they reach
a gallop so the fastest speed that they
run at so what a racehorse would do
and all it means is that every time they
pick up their front legs they inhale and
every time their front legs hit the
ground they exhale and they can't change
that the only way they can change their
breathing is to change their f their
stride frequency so if they want to
breathe faster then they have to
increase their stride frequency and if
they don't need to breathe as quickly
then they can slow their stride
frequency
but they cannot hyperventilate
intentionally like we can
whoa wow
that's pretty well now is that
is that something that they call up or
is that just tied to all of their
movements yeah the whole physiology and
enviro i mean
and part of it the reason for it is it
actually makes breathing more efficient
so
whenever they
inhale so when they pick those four legs
up if you actually look at the horse's
body it almost turns kind of we think
about it like a bow and an arrow or a
bow and string and so the bow would be
the top his back and then the string
would be his belly and if you think
about when the horse picks his front
legs up that bow comes up the back
raises and then that leaves more space
in the abdomen to actually pull the
diaphragm back with negative pressure
helping to pull air into the lungs okay
so the whole thing works in symphony
and then when he puts his front feet
down the abdomen comes up helps push
that ox or the actual air out through
the lungs and so it takes less energy
for him to breathe because he's using
that natural movement
okay right we gotta take a quick break
but stay with us with dr sarah white
springer and we're gonna ask her what is
precision management for horses and what
does that mean the answer is on the
other side of this break
start sports edition
we're back start talk sports edition
horsepower with dr sarah white springer
who's
uh who's in what is sarah
your department is just animal science
department but you're specializing in
horses within that department is that
correct that's correct yeah okay very
cool and you're an assistant professor
there as your title yeah for a couple
more months
oh getting tenure on the 10-year
doorstep yep that's word on the street
word on the street well well we we fully
expect that to happen thank you all
right all right good luck anyway because
sometimes you need a little bit of that
so so sarah let me just start off by
saying how do you
make your horse go faster is it the is
it the muscle is it the skeleton is it
the diet is it how hard they get whipped
on their ass by the jockey
what is it
if i had that answer i'd be retired
so it's a combination so
we they have to be bred right they have
to have the right genetics they have to
be built right they have to be fed right
they have to be managed right um and
they all are individuals and that's what
makes it the most difficult
we talk a lot about how do we quantify
performance in horses because the
easiest way to quantify would be a
racehorse one would think they run
faster they don't
however
some horses like dirt some horses like
turf some horses like when it rains some
of them don't some of them are just
really competitive and i actually have
this is not a dr seuss story here it is
story
this is how i make my living through dr
seuss horse research
some like it in a in a boat in a train
on a plane
like running under those conditions
correct yeah doctor with with track and
field athletes
and have no horsey background whatsoever
but you might carb load in
the lead up to in humans
for humans
infusing your your your bloodstream
with very accessible
uh carbohydrate energy totally so
have have have horses been carb loaded
successfully is is it something that
they're
they're you that can be useful for them
and their performance and is that why i
see them eating crap loads of spaghetti
spaghetti dinner the night before
they love spaghetti that has nothing to
do with carb-loading everything because
horses love spaghetti they like
spaghetti cool
kidding
so
i'm sorry
uh no yeah yes it's been tried no it
doesn't work um so horses have a really
high glycogen content in their muscle
glycogen is a storage form of sugar
sugar and it's the most readily is
readably accessible
uh form of energy right for immediate
needs
so unfortunately there's not a whole lot
we can do to change that we've tried in
horses just like in humans where they
give a large sugar meal or a large
carbohydrate meal um and it it doesn't
change the glycogen depletion rate in
the horse so
but in humans
we use up that glycogen and then we our
body goes and finds stored reserves
converts it into sugar so that we can
continue to have fuel
so does that process still happen in
horses or is it just like they got all
the glycogen they need
so
the process happens but it's it's the
replenishment of that glycogen that
takes longer so
they
with humans part of the reason we carb
load is to make sure that all of that
sugar is stored and ready and to make
sure that blood sugar is high enough
right because we're going to use blood
sugar first and then stores of sugar
like glycogen and the muscle
so in the horse
you can't do anything to really change
those ratios so you can give a large
grain meal and it's really not going to
change a whole lot part of the problem
there too is you don't want to have a
ton of gut fill right before you
exercise especially at a high speed or a
high intensity as you can imagine if
you've tried to eat a large meal and
then go for a quick run it's not the
most comfortable in the world
it also if you feed a large meal before
exercise all of that blood flow is
diverted to the gut to help process that
meal
and so now it's not going to be diverted
to the working muscle or
for thermoregulation to the skin that's
why we throw up do they throw up
we can't
oh man so they just stopped they're just
like look i can't do no more
look yeah i already unbuckled my third
belt
oh man this saddle is killing me
and i have a mirror that would have that
exact response oh my god
so doctor you said earlier on in the
show about
some of your research work was
focusing on how you get certain minerals
to activate mitochondria in a in a
higher performance way
what are they
and how are you just giving them you're
going to cvs or any other pharmacy get
some multivits and just
put them in their feed or how are we how
would we get from for horses
[Laughter]
funny you say that because we don't go
to cvs but there's there's kind of a
similar concept in in creating different
feed ingredients um
it's you know that's the problem we
there's so much we don't know so there's
my favorite mineral of choice is
selenium
um there's quite a bit of research
showing that just a slightly elevated
level of selenium enhances mitochondrial
biogenesis so we get more of them and it
enhances mitochondrial capacity you give
them walnuts
no we don't give them walnuts we just
because they're high in selenium
yeah i don't think that they would eat
walnuts i don't have a horse that's
eating a walnut um but we there's
different forms of selenium so there's
selenium yeast there's selenium
methionine there's
selenium selenite in organisms i have to
interject because i'm a big fan of the
periodic table of elements that selenium
is named after the moon
named after moonlight and it was
discovered and paired
with in a pair of elements with this
other element that they named after the
earth so there's tellurium and selenium
which were discovered together and named
together after the earth and the moon
that's interesting
it's commercial brought to you by the
periodic table
okay and now a star goes over neil's
head
okay so sarah please continue so
selenium is good all right
to an extent so here's the problem
selenium is also highly toxic
and so if they get too much of it i
don't know if you remember back to 2009
in south florida 21 polo ponies
collapsed on the field and either died
or had to be euthanized oh my god i
thought that was just a protest well may
have been
by someone other than the owner
but um yeah they they found out those
those horses they used to inject with
the antioxidant cocktail immediately
before a performance trying to enhance
performance by decreasing oxidative
stress
well the selenium dose got off by 1.1 so
one decimal place
and it killed 21 horses wow man and
those horses cost a lot of money
like they are super expensive yep yep so
that's very capitalist of you a horse
died and you're talking about how much
they cost
let's have a moment for the dead horse
please yeah if my grandmother died i'd
be like i don't know how much this is
going to cost
[Laughter]
well let me remind our audience chuck is
a comedian
he loves his grandmother yes i do very
much we're into the sort of
mitochondrial aspect of things
to see how this whole energy
chain happens
but invariably to
run faster bigger muscles
and it's not if you put a multi-gym in a
stable and just say to the horses there
you go
um
how do you develop muscle strength
in a horse well so that's that's the
question sarah is we know how to
increase muscle uh duration stamina
strength
by isolating them with these suite of
instruments right what do horses have to
do the same thing or is that not what
happens and is it the same process i
mean our muscles build because we
literally tear them down and it's the
healing process that makes the muscle so
is it the same for horses so the process
is the same
the problem is in humans we can very
easily separate the strength from the
endurance training right if we want an
endurance train we do some sort of
cardio so we run row whatever
um if we want to strength train we
isolate that muscle group so bicep curls
whatever you want to do i don't do any
of those things but
in the horse fair enough
you're my new hero
there you go
that'll do it have a good time you're
both binging netflix on a couch right no
my left arm is really strong because
he's only 10 months old and he weighs 25
pounds so i carry him only because i'm
less coordinated with my right arm oh
your son you're talking about yes yes
that's a texas corn fed baby right there
oh my goodness that's a fullback you
tell me if you're down and where
football is a religion yeah yeah they're
all ready
they're already buying that kid pads and
a helmet
honey i'm so ready
anyway i don't even know where i was
going with that but um so horses we
can't separate those two types of
exercise if they're doing some sort of
strength training to engage those muscle
groups they also have to be running
right they have to be moving somewhere
where they're using the cardiovascular
system
so
it's hard and how we do that is just in
a racehorse essentially we just make
them do more sprints because more
sprints are going to engage that
hindquarter a lot more than a slower
pace would
in some horses we can start to integrate
different exercises if you're um if
someone's in a spot where there's like
hills that's actually going up a hill
engages a lot of the hindquarter as well
and so that is kind of a strength or a
muscle um hypertrophy type stimulus so
doctor we we've we've seen horses being
doped
um
and
we've seen their if their winners have
that wind taken away from them and
trainers and all sorts of people get in
trouble
what are they doping with and for what
kind of results are they looking for
what are they not doping with
um
yeah that's a good question so most
they're always tr everybody wants an
edge and so they're always trying
something we've heard um beta 2 agonists
which are used in meat production
they increase muscle mass and so people
have tried that in horses that are
primarily bred for sprint because we
want bigger muscles in those guys
i've heard
there's
one
oh gosh bisphosphonates my brain just
went blink so bisphosphonates are used
in human medicine to help with
osteoporosis because it prevents bone
breakdown and there's concern that
people were using it off label in horses
and young horses to make their bones
appear stronger on x-ray problem is when
young horses their bone doesn't break
down it can't remodel and so
when you don't get remodeling with
growth now you actually have a more
brittle bone by the time you go to
exercise and
and is that kind of like sewing you know
testicles on a goat is is that the idea
behind why is why why is anything in the
universe
related to that sentence
okay so
connect without anything that has ever
happened in the history of the universe
okay so what i was really asking is is
that a means of defrauding a buyer into
thinking that you have a uh you know a
superior horse uh but the sewing the
testicles on the goat is um in certain
island cultures
male goats are worth a hell of a lot
more
than the female goats and so when you
wanted to defraud somebody you would sew
testicles on the female goat and then
you were interesting that we
on this call and everyone list in the
audience audible range of this knew
about this island practice
feel smarter for being here today
name the island i want i want i want a
geographical location
okay yeah okay anyway is that a means of
defrauding people like if they're buying
a horse
yes or no you know
just because they
they're doing it as a precaution so all
thoroughbreds have to have x-rays at
sale to make sure that they do have good
legs gotcha um and so i think it's
i don't i think it's just it was
something they thought well this will
make sure that they have good legs right
right
and again none of this stuff is proven
so we don't know how common it is or
it's all
who knows
but um there's a whole slew of things
anything that people here can maybe
enhance performance enhance muscle
health enhance bone strength they'll try
it because they want the up they want
the the advantage so
yeah
it's uh
the big thing is you can't you don't get
to find out what a lot of those things
are because it's also hush hush right
right
so sir before we take our second and
last break uh just we realize how much
money there is in horse racing and
show jumping you know it's an elite
thing
yet
you don't have all the money you could
use to do the research you need to do
so why why doesn't somebody just tax all
of that and have it go into equine
research at land grant universities
wouldn't that be a cool source of money
yeah i'd be good with that okay
solve that problem
it's
not everyone's involved right it's a
huge industry i mean the economic impact
is incredible but i think
it's looked at as an elitist sport and
so it's looked at as something that not
everyone can partake in even though
that's not actually true because there's
different levels
but i think that there's just not enough
support you know something like that
would have to be voted on right and i
don't know how we would convince the
general public that this is important
enough to support all right well we come
back uh more with our good professor
from the texas a m who was telling us
all about horses stuff we never even
knew was something to know and maybe
we'll talk a little bit about uh her
dressage work and what that's all about
on star talk sports edition
we're back third and final segment uh
star talk sports edition
horsepower dr sarah white springer uh
soon to be
word on the street associate professor
of equine science in the in the animal
animal department animal sciences animal
science department so so your funding
comes primarily from where
so we um there's a couple agencies that
actually work a lot with the
thoroughbreds and they do offer some
competitive grants so the grayson jockey
club they're based there in lexington
kentucky and i know some of the farms
like windstar have specific grants that
they are specific um calls that they can
offer money towards to help with these
different research grants and and so
that one is really a good one for the
thoroughbreds also the american quarter
horse foundation um has their own
specific call of research grants and so
those ones are available they're not the
largest brands in the world but they're
at least options that we have and are
supported by the industry um so we're
able to get some dollars okay cool
very good very good so gary where else
were you going to take sarah on this
well
we can't have the good doctor on
and not address dressage
or as uh snoop dogg said recently [ __ ]
walking for horses
um which i must admit made me laugh um
but that's another story for a chisel
exactly so doctor when you've got a
horse and you can make it run fast i
understand that the sort of
the the thing that's going on there but
with dressage
this is a different kind of horse power
this is all about control this is all
about how you get
this horse to be in harmony with
the rider so
how does this development happen how
does this relationship
go and what sort of work do you have to
do to get the power in the horse so as
it can perform these amazing feats
so it's funny since we were just talking
about uh strength training dressage is
one of the disciplines that we can
really identify some strength exercises
so if you watch the olympics one of the
moves they do is called a p off and it's
where they trot in place
so you'll see they'll be trotting and
then they'll stop and they'll continue
to do it and so they have sarah when i
say while they're trying they're showing
off it's very clear yeah it's mainly
that riders are totally showing off when
they trot in place yeah i don't know i
have no other explanation for it the
most vain horses always win
yes a little bit of that is not far from
true which is a little sad but um yeah
so that's they're lifting themselves and
their rider and that's a lot of weight
right i mean that could be close to 1800
pounds and so
depending on the horse and so you have a
very different type of training so we're
not just going fast and going forward we
have to learn to be teach the horse to
be supple so he needs to be able to bend
through his rib cage to really you'll
notice and they when they do that
movement the pee off they sit they
almost look like they're sitting in the
hind end because they have to carry so
much of that weight on the hind quarter
in order to maintain that type of uh
movement and so it should be so
light-footed on their front on their
front legs yeah and naturally a horse
carries 60 of his body weight on his
front legs and 40 on his rear and so you
really have to teach him how to move
that back and that's a really difficult
thing to do that's core strengths yes i
mean you can't sit that horse down
saying go and do some abs i haven't
thought about that because the plank yes
the horse's huge neck and head
sticks forward of the front legs correct
and the only thing that sticks rearward
of the rear legs is the tail
so clearly then the front legs have most
of the weight i hadn't thought about
that yeah yeah
yeah and when you see injuries they
actually tend to happen in the front leg
too because they're carrying that extra
weight
and how do they
how do you get a horse to do something
like that you know it's like it's not
like they're going on dancing with the
mayors and they get to just get together
and they have a little dance teacher
it's how do you get a horse to
trot in place
or did you do any of those things or any
of those things any of those things
right yeah you're so picky yeah and not
not only you're right because some of
those moves are straight-up dance moves
yes right like yeah yeah a lot of years
daunting
my favorite one is when they when they
sort of do us a sachet sideways oh yeah
like
half passes yep yeah yeah because how
many animals other than crabs ever move
sideways sideways like none of them
right yeah and it's very difficult
because then that's more muscles you
have to develop right those adductors
and abductors to help move those legs
sideways
um chuck does she say those slow enough
for you
yeah i mean humans have those too it's
just a ton
yeah so what happens doctor if
your horse
you're just about to go into an event
your horse looks at you and says you
know what i just do not fancy it today
you can do one
what what
because horses have their own characters
so what happens you just pray and hope
that you can make it hold it together
for the next four minutes or so
i've definitely been there
yeah very cool by the time you get to
that point of competition
you're hoping you always train harder at
home than you have to compete that's
just to make sure that the horse is
strong enough to meet that competition
level and so your hope is that even if
your horse decides that he doesn't feel
like playing today
you're good enough that you can can keep
it together and make a good enough
picture for the next couple minutes so
that's intro that chuck that mantra you
train harder than you play yeah i mean
that's that's the sign of a champion
ryan yeah that's a sign of every
champion that's how that works the game
the game is a lighter lift than practice
right yeah that's how that so the game
should just be a nothing just another
another outing right yeah correct see
the your performance
and we had this with the triathlete uh
mark mark allen remember him the
triathlete chuck that runs forever yeah
he anything that he did in a race was
inside his comfort zone
right yeah and he rarely had to leave to
get a performance to win because he
trained so much harder and that's what
you'll find um especially in
dressage horses that there's different
levels of dressage at the olympics
you'll see the grand prix level that's
the highest we go
but it starts at training level and so
there's different levels and there's
different skills that the horse should
know at each of those levels and
typically what you'll find is those
horses that are competing they're
schooling a level higher than they're
competing at
so they can do all of the movements at
the next level but only at home
no and so when they compete they're
actually competing a level down
because they want they want that to be
easy they don't want their hardest
movements to be at the competition
how long does it take to if i get walked
in you said this horse looks like the
real deal but it doesn't have a clue
it has three left feet there you go um
how long does it take in on average to
to get that relationship to be
successful i would say
to get to a train so to start competing
maybe six months you could get there um
to get up to that high level probably
eight years or so
oh
geez wow that's serious
sarah so how about like the cutter
horses
so are these horses with these talents
are they bred that way or are they
trained to be that way
both um they have to be bred
to be built a certain way so you can't
confirmation you can't change however
they come out however they're built it's
pretty much what you get and then you
can just change musculature from there
oh man you just gave me a great idea for
a disney film
it it's a donkey that wants to do
dressage oh there you go the dressage
donkey okay you need eddie murphy as the
voice of the donkey yeah okay have you
seen a cow that jumps i think that's in
england england maybe a cow that jumps
yeah there's a girl that rides a cow and
it jumps okay but i don't think they
made it over the moon just yet they have
to work on that one oh that's my second
dad joke sorry
how jumping i knew that more in you um
so in the cutter horse they make eye
contact with like one of the sheep or
something they cut it from the herd yeah
that's an amazing thing to watch yeah
and so you're saying some of that is
breeding and some of that is training
yep and some too so we talked about
horse personalities so we call horses
that really have a want to do that we
call them cowie how cowy are they how
much do they really like to get in there
and move the animals and you'll find
that that differs just based on the
individual because you talked about
precision management earlier we have to
remember that horses are individuals and
they're going to require forces are
people too horses are people too and so
they have to be fed and managed and
trained differently based on their
personality
so i got to start ending this segment
because we spent so much time in the
first two segments we
squeezed this one down
so i want to ask just sort of a final
question here when i look at the fastest
running
animals
you look at the cheetah you look at
the greyhound
dog you look at
some other cats
when they run their spine
coils
okay and then springs
and coils back and then springs
and one thing is true about horses their
back does not coil it basically stays
flat relative to what you see a
greyhound do or cheater do
should we instead be breeding flexy back
horses
if we want them to run as fast as they
possibly could so they actually do coil
just not as much as you can see on the
outside
i'm talking about it more
hey you give me enough money
yeah so if you can it's really
interesting that we didn't talk about so
the tendons down the back of the leg are
really interesting as well if you
actually watch when the front feet hit
their wall both front and back hit the
ground you'll see that the fetlock which
is the joint just above the hoof it
almost goes down to touch the ground
that tendon that's behind that that
joint
stores energy right so as soon as that
foot comes off the ground now that
tendon's like an elastic rubber band
springs back and helps to pick that leg
up so that it can come down again okay
and so it's another kind of efficient
way that the horse uses that he doesn't
have to use extra energy to move those
limbs because it's being stored in those
tendons i still think they should have
flexi backs that's really
maybe you all get to retire before i
will and then and then you got to build
a special thing for the jockey to sit on
because they can't stay on a flexi back
imagine a jockey on the back of a
cheetah that just wouldn't work right
right
for multiple reasons just saying guys we
got to call it quits there sarah it has
been a delight to have you and we know
you're going to make that transition
from assistant professor to full
professor if not you have have them call
us okay
exactly
my recommendation letters are coming
from from here on out
we'll let them know you you're about to
make a slinky horse and they'll
everybody's going to be rich
all right chuck always good to have you
gary it's a pleasure good to have you
here and dr white springer we're gonna
have to do this again because we're not
done figuring out how horses work yeah
this is awesome thank you excellent neil
degrasse tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking up
[Music]
you